[Applause]
joining us now by the way I got a copy
right here author of The Trial of the
century soon to be released Fox News
legal analyst Greg Jarrett and the
author of you got it it's right here get
Trump and that's Harvard Law Professor
Alan dershowitz in studio
thank you for having me John we
appreciate you being with us I know you
agree with me about you know the
extremists on any side we look I got
powder too my secretary had to be hosed
down taken to Mass General Hospital the
same day the Wall Street Journal got it
mine did have some
stuff in it that was very negative and
she had to be treated wow nobody should
be treated that way I lived at my
assistant I mean was in tears for hours
scared to death rightly so
um never mind the fat wall that was put
on my head that was an experience too a
long time ago I only had a fatwa put on
by Martha's Vineyard and it's not it's
not as scary up there you know a little
sand in my face you know a few dinner
there's love there until you said you
stood up for the law yeah and you said
no what they're doing to Trump is unfair
that's what happened that's right
exactly yeah all right let me ask you
this first of all
let's talk about the lawsuit that Donald
Trump has filed against Michael move
good move
lawyers should not be violated
violent privilege number one number two
he gets Discovery if he survives a
motion to dismiss and he's going to be
able to find out things that the
government wouldn't turn over to him in
a criminal trial so I think it's a very
smart are you assuming that he's
preserved all this information and isn't
it likely that a lot of it doesn't exist
well you know it's very hard these days
to hide things forever with the internet
with social media if you get the right
people you can get things that people
think they've hidden so I'm glad we're
going to get to the bottom of this look
transparency is essential if people have
nothing to hide they shouldn't be
worried let's bring in Greg chair Greg
your take on Trump's suit against
Michael Cohen
well it's a legitimate suit it's
actionable in a court of law it centers
around the many lies of Michael Cohen
this is a guy who lied to the IRS why do
U.S banks lie to Congress and went to
prison for it and Trump claims in his
lawsuit he too is a victim causing
reputational damage but on top of that
what jumped out at me at the lawsuit is
that it claims that Cohen committed
theft and unjust enrichment by
defrauding Trump over a phony business
venture and pocketed an exorbitant
amount of money over something that did
not exist uh you know on top of that
there's also a breach of fiduciary duty
which is pretty darn clear with Cohen
and breach of contract you know it's bad
enough that prosecutors called him a
greedy liar and the judge who sentenced
him said he committed a veritable
Smorgasbord of fraudulent crimes and
deceit uh can can you imagine a district
attorney using a guy like that as his
star witness the problem with inveterate
Liars is you never know when you're
getting scammed and it's hard to tell
the jury believe this guy he's told so
many lies you would need a calculator to
keep track of it and so questions it
raises ethical questions a district
attorney cannot put a witness on the
stand who he reasonably believes may be
lying to the jury now how can Bragg put
this man on the witness stand he's an
admitted liar in a combat 12 people I
vouch for him now he's telling the truth
you know Cohn wrote to me recently
because I threatened to sue him because
he told the lie about me he had me on
Jeffrey Epstein's island with young
people I've never been anywhere with
young people you were on orgy Island
that's what he says that's what he said
just asking and it's not is not true so
I am threatening to sue him because well
because you know when governments go
after Witnesses they'll do anything
they'll twist they'll turn they'll
threaten with they'll threaten relatives
they'll threaten everything it's about
time a defendant said I'm going to fight
back I'm going to assume the person and
I'll get Discovery too let's even the
playing field let's level the plane last
question will Bragg's lawsuit against
Jim Jordan hold up uh Greg Jarrett
no it won't hold up the judge will not
Grant a temporary restraining order uh
you know I it is so amazing that Alvin
Bragg said any uh this is an
unconstitutional attack on his
unconstitutional indictment and then he
also said oh if I answer questions uh it
will disclose secretive confidential
Communications well his assistant wrote
a tell-all book disclosing all the
sensitive confidential information so
this is a lawsuit that will not succeed
all right Greg's book is coming out
shortly uh this book at Trump uh talks
about all the cases legally that Donald
Trump is facing uh big uh Applause for
Alberta
Gary hey Sean Hannity here hey click
here to subscribe to Fox News YouTube
page and catch our hottest interviews
and most compelling analysis you will
not get it anywhere else